make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob and we
are picking back up again with uh
darkseid war and in this instance we're
covering the
shazam one shot when billy batson gets a
new pantheon of gods now
here's a crazy thing about this right
this was probably one of the most
anticipated and exciting things to come
out of dark side war and for those of
you guys who are new to comic books this
is usually how it works right if you
guys are familiar with comics that's
awesome
bear with me here for a minute while we
kind of get people who are not really
familiar with comics caught up
so usually when it comes to a particular
character or team more often than not
uh publishers or at least it used to be
this way publishers would use like big
landmark events as a way to kind of
reshuffle and
change things more recently it just kind
of changes based on any one new
particular writer right they just kind
of introduce a story arc shift things up
and then some kind of change gets made
that just gets carried on
from that point going forward with dark
side war this is one of the instances
when dc was just kind of like let's
change things up for shazam right let's
shift things around and let's let's
introduce like a new pantheon of gods
right now
it's as it is a good time as any and so
what we ended up getting was that during
the main dark side
war event following the death of
darkseid there was this kind of ripple
effect that was sent throughout
essentially the the realm of the gods
and the results of this is that billy
batson lost his connection to the old
gods mercury and and zeus and
and so on and so forth you know solomon
and whatnot and he was replaced or
really was replaced with
a with a new god and even then even
inside of this is called the six gods of
antiquity
antique gods that's kind of what they're
referred to as now when this happens
there's this kind of huge influx of all
these different voices that come pouring
into his head
because for the most part they're as new
to this as he is right they're not
really sure why they're bound to him and
he's not really sure where these new
gods came from
it's suddenly just this huge influx of
voices from all these various beings
he's discovering new
powers the ability to manipulate what's
called the living fire as opposed to
simply just being the the living
lightning in a traditional sense and so
it leads to them kind of goading him on
and almost kind of just being like you
know shout the word right you know say
shazam different things like that and
ultimately he initially does but then
suddenly he's whisked away
basically to the source now the way the
dc explains this
is that gods in dc comics never actually
die
instead they're basically taken to the
source now the important thing to
understand here
this is kind of a jack kirby thing but
kind of not uh the reason why i say that
is is back in the 70s when jack kirby
left marvel and then went to dc comics
he had his whole fourth world right the
idea of jack kirby doing that he kind of
sidetracked from this for a second
the idea of jack kirby introducing like
darkseid and all those guys
in the old the old fourth world comics
was to create like a holy separate
publication
that didn't really have anything to do
with the mainline dc comics kind of what
you see now with like vertigo right it's
like lucifer and like the specter things
like that
spectre crosses over more often than not
but you've never really seen a story
where like superman and wonder woman in
the justice league have to like align
themselves with lucifer morningstar
to face off against some kind of threat
uh but the idea with the fourth world
was to make it wholly separate and
unique and the source was a part of that
and all that kind of good stuff
the whole thing behind this is that
following him leaving dc
all the fourth world stuff was rolled
over into the main dc universe which is
why you have dark side
it's part of like the the new 52 or you
had dark side even before that he would
face off against superman and things
along those lines
but the idea of god's dying and going to
the source was a concept that jack kirby
had thought of but not one that was
routinely used and in fact it really
wouldn't be
until neil gaiman's eternals in marvel
comics that that concept by jack kirby
was actually used more prominently when
you figured out that's where the
celestials go that when celestials and
marvel comics die they go to a kind of
afterlife for the celestials they rejoin
quote unquote marvel's version of the
source that's kind of rolled over here
right so it's one of those things where
it was kind of created by dc but not
really never never really used that it
was used by marvel then it was used by
dc but it all really kind of roots back
to jack kirby which is why he's
considered to be
one of the most landmark people out
there but what dc basically establishes
here is that the old gods that shazam
was previously tied to
are not really dead they simply just
rejoin the source and at some point
along the line it basically opens the
door for them to return
in some form or fashion so like solomon
hercules atlas zeus achilles mercury
they're not really tied
to shazam anymore instead he's got a
whole new pantheon but the crazy thing
about this
is that when steve orlando wrote this it
was designed to kind of
springboard into a new series of shazam
stories and a lot of that was because
shazam's comics is as interesting as he
was and as hardcore as his fan following
is
even they would have to admit the
biggest problem with billy batson is the
story's run stagnant that they don't
really
do a lot with his character he's there
but the last time he really had
anything great was during the early 90s
when you learned that like when he turns
into shazam he turns into what he
remembers his father looking like or
what he what he imagines his father to
look like or something along those lines
but like that's it right there really
haven't been a lot of meaningful moments
behind billy batson
and so this was kind of designed to say
okay well let's just get rid of his old
gods replace him with new gods and then
go from there
and so what we're basically told is that
in this interim moment like this this
split moment of a second between the
time that that dark side died
and the time that billy was given these
new these new abilities that
time was kind of frozen to a degree that
it works differently when it comes to
gods but the idea is that the old gods
were removed the new gods were put in
but it was an incomplete process that
the wizard shazam was the one who
started it but before the transition
could be completed that a villain named
zonus had basically struck and he was
kind of going through the process
of essentially eliminating or taking
over all these old gods and then kind of
empowering himself
and what we're basically told is that
before darkseid or any of those guys
there was just like this this kind of
butcher right this this primal
inspiration for suffering right he's
basically given to us as like the
original incarnation of
evil now again this is not really
designed to stand alongside vertigo it's
designed to stand
kind of alone from vertigo right so
that's why you don't really see any
correlation here with regards to how
this guy
zone is compares to like lucifer
morningstar or something like that just
no real there's
dc doesn't just doesn't really cross
those things over too much but the idea
is that shazam having this new level of
power
would basically put him in a position to
overpower zonus right to kind of confine
him back to where he's supposed to be
and so in the midst of that conversation
when he's talking to this woman uh
annapelle
you know as part of his new pantheon
suddenly he's yanked away and he ends up
coming into
uh this guy who basically refers to
himself as siva the dancer of
destruction
and each one of these instances each one
of these gods that he comes across with
kind of gives them a little
a little more of a piece of the puzzle
right that in the sense that where zone
is kind of gone in this campaign of
cruelty and whatnot that ultimately he
was defeated right and when he was
defeated his cruelty was replaced with
his son's cruelty that his son became
you know equally cruel to him and so the
result of this is that when he's met
with these new powers they kind of
question him whether or not he could
actually use these powers effectively
whether he could channel these abilities
in the right way
to actually defeat zonus like does this
kid have the power to pull that off but
before he's really able to provide any
credible evidence to the fact
that he can do this outside of you know
don't question what it is that i'm
capable of if that's if you guys really
see me as just some common mortal
then none of you really understand what
i'm about then suddenly he's yanked away
and then he's brought to the presence of
a woman by the name of ate who's the
goddess of impulse and the way she kind
of explains herself here is really
intriguing she really establishes the
idea that where the other people lend
him particular abilities
she lends him a concept right she lends
him the idea of being
impulsive and this could be looked at as
a bad thing but not necessarily and the
reason why
is because whenever two foes go into
conflict with each other there's this
kind of expectation
in terms of how things will play out
right in the sense that zonus kind of
being this ancient evil that is
basically returned would look at billy
batson in a lot of ways underestimate
him right or at the very least say okay
if you're empowered by these gods that
i'm familiar with then knowing those
gods as i do
i would expect you to act something in
the same fashion because
why else would they give you their
powers and even then he would look at
him as somebody just being an earthling
and say okay as a person from earth i
can expect you to act like most
earthlings
impulsiveness kind of grants this sort
of distraction right this idea that you
know it kind of throws them off guard
like what is he gonna do next that kind
of a thing
acting in an impulsive manner and even
then it's kind of expanded to a degree
right the idea
that you know this this offering that
she brings to him could be something
that could distract him from the beating
he's going to get now she's not really
saying that insofar as a
something being beneficial she's kind of
saying it from the perspective of like
you're probably going to get wrecked
right so not really having a whole lot
of faith in him but again before he's
able to kind of explain it to her before
he's able to offer any real indication
of what it is that he's about
he suddenly yanked away again and he's
almost brought to the to this guy who
looks very similar to what we'd expect
from like certain or
even like hephaestus from greek
mythology now he calls himself ron mere
which he kind of says like there is
nobody else out there like me now the
truth about this
is he grants him what's called the
living fire which is more or less
something akin to the living lightning
we didn't really we don't really know
the full
effect of what his fire can do the full
on like
level of durability and and you know how
it compares to something like hellfire
or something along those lines
because of course he's yanked away and
then suddenly he's brought before the
wizard shazam who's facing off against
zonus that with zonas being free that
now he's going through and trying to
take out each one of these individual
gods now when he shows up here
billy of course watches the wizard get
into this conflict and then zones
reveals his true nature
in saying that he's basically yuga khan
right the sire of evil that he's the
actual father of
side now this is not the first time that
we've seen yuka khan
in dc comics he existed long before this
but you know the last time we'd
previously seen him he was locked away
in the source wall so presumably he had
managed to find some way to escape now
the fact that he's here is one of these
things where it's kind of like he
intends to use his power combined with
the powers of the other gods presumably
through billy batson to basically raise
the world and kind of sees his son as a
failure right the idea that like he's
picking up where darkseid left off that
dark side was just not strong enough to
be able to overtake the world he wasn't
strong enough to be able to overtake
earth's superheroes but that yuga khan
himself
can now the idea behind this was to kind
of again springboard
into like new stories that could be told
coming in the aftermath of darkseid war
and initially like he just kind of takes
off right headed towards earth now billy
batson of course
transforms into the wizard shazam and
brandishing the power of these new gods
that he possesses
goes toe-to-toe with yuga khan and is
able to actually overpower him
just by the the strength speed
durability all that kind of stuff he's
able to overpower him even when you have
yuka khan who's playing mind games and
saying like nothing you do can stop me
and i will take your friends and i will
put them in the kilns and you will watch
them burn and you will smell them as
they die
like just all these these horrible
things that he's putting inside of his
head
at the end of the day none of it matters
and he's still able to present himself
as the earth's mightiest mortal now
that's the point that billy was trying
to get across to all these new gods who
questioned whether or not he would have
the ability to overcome somebody like
yuga khan and saying
that the beauty of humanity is that
we're not inherently limited that a lot
of races out there or a lot of beings
out there may be confined to this kind
of world view or this view of their
existence or something like that and
in that limitation they quite literally
cannot think outside the box but humans
are driven
and powered by their imagination and the
things that come with it and so because
of that billy doesn't really see
any limits to his power and it's one of
these rare instances when you see
him almost kind of like a level of power
that seemingly has no real limit
now the reason why i say that is because
there are big differences between the
powers that billy had before and the
powers he has now
a lot of them are still the same they're
having like super strength and like
super speed and things like that right
the lightning of mammorag and that's
that's
not really a huge difference in what we
saw before but having this kind of
boldness
that comes from eight right the ability
to manipulate the power of the source
which came from zonas
having the ability to manipulate the
fires of ron mir this was all brand new
stuff but no matter how you slice
it the result is that he overpowers yuga
khan and then essentially knocks him out
and so when that happens we have a
couple things that happen
the first is that we learn the actual
name of the wizard shazam who says his
name is mammaragan right so this is kind
of a big reveal
when it first happened and that man
wagon was basically the fifth god that
billy was getting his powers from the
sixth
source of his power came from yuba khan
himself but the important takeaway from
all this
is that billy basically had a new source
of power that he could use in stories
going forward the downside of this is
we never really saw anything come of it
right because dark side war ended and
then
dc comics almost immediately picked up
with the events of rebirth and just kind
of
blew all this off right so dark side war
was just kind of ignored seemingly
across the board outside of reference to
the fact that it happened
we didn't really see anything from billy
batson outside of him showing up in like
a constantine comic
maybe some wonder woman stories but
nothing of any real significance to give
us this idea that like steve orlando's
vision of catapulting into like a new
era of storytelling focusing on shazam
with a whole new level of power we never
got to see that right which is really
disappointing when you think about it
because it was a way to just breathe
fresh life into a character who for
quite some time has seemingly just kind
of become stagnant but
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to comments explain make sure
you guys hit the sub button to become
part of the rob core if you guys enjoy
this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
do
you